he's John C McKinley the full full
introduction here new season of stand
against evil that returns October 31st
can be seen Wednesdays at 10 p.m. on IFC
so he plays the disgruntled former
police sheriff Stanley Miller so these
stand against evil good to see you you
go full orson welles intro voice when
you start reading intros okay and i love
your voice you but delicious chocolatey
voice thank you massage that thing thank
you go intro thank you John yeah you go
down and Orson Welles he's a sour ageing
Bulldog who has recently lost his
position as head honcho that's my guy
angry velvet at your wife's funeral well
that's my John Fish endo right there yes
I just drop you know in a world I always
wanted to do those movie promos well
there's one guy who doesn't my no I know
what's his name Don you know they didn't
move it they did a movie yeah do you
guys remember LaFontaine yes good Paul
yeah in a world this is no longer with
us
yeah jobs open Danny died in 2008 okay
alright well I got us in peace John can
put in a good word for me okay some of
the other things that you've been in
scrubs Point Break 7 the rock platoon
anything else someone throw in there you
went to NYU grew up right around here
Giants fan you got your Giants hat no
hun I do I bleed giant blue are you
really yeah I told you my grandfather
play for the 1927 Giants did dude the
Giants make you cry no I'm not a big
sports crier
when they won their Super Bowl no I was
I mean I was really that was at what 11
1/2 point spread the last one yeah when
the Patriots were coming off that
undefeated season no that was that was
half a beer that was that was happy do
you gamble I used to a ton and then I
was putting too much homework into it
because there was this dopey everybody
put a hundred bucks into a pool when we
were doing scrubs and I'm a film crews
about a hundred people or so so it was
not a it was not a shy number and I
started doing too much homework and it
was just one of those dopey death pools
or whatever you call them where you pick
a team every week
and I made it into the 8th week and I
started to really want the 10 grand or
whatever was it what's a 100 times a
hundred grand and it was too silly so I
stopped how many episodes of scrubs did
you guys do almost 200 Wow is there one
like when you how surprised are you what
it was in what it became very I mean it
was a great gig
but it was a grind because we were just
shooting single-camera it wasn't a
sitcom it wasn't four cameras and with
an audience it was 14 hours a day and so
it was a grind we spent much more time
as I'm sure maybe you do we spent much
more time with the cast and crew than we
did with our families for that um we
started the month before 9/11 and then
we finished at the end of the decade so
it was that decade but if you look at
toughness as far as TV movies or stage
the order of difficulty a dude doing a
Broadway play I was lucky enough to do
Glengarry with Al Pacino and Bobby kind
of Ollie about when we sandy five years
ago four years ago so we were there when
Sandy happened and the hurricane and
that's the hardest thing
how was like when you're there with
Pacino how is it different like no
because I I had gotten a little owl love
down in Miami because we did any given
Sunday together that's right which is I
think why I was in Glengarry and so I
had already
Johnny Cusack who's my dear friend and a
big fan of yours told me and they had
done City Hall together ten years prior
to any given Sunday and I said to Johnny
what do I do about Al Pacino when I get
down to Miami and he goes you gotta go
knock on his door I'm like this feels
feels like the biggest set of all time
because you know then Geno comes out and
punches me in the esophagus and I'm like
I would just wanted to meet out and so I
go this is not a setup right he goes no
and so we're down in Miami and it was a
very dispersed set with a lot of stars
and I happen to be near Al's trailer and
I went over and knocked on it and he was
just like John C come in come in this
would be great I've been wanted to talk
to you I'm like you're calling me John C
and you're saying I've been wanting to
talk to me
okay yeah and so I called Johnny back
and I said yeah that was a win put in a
good word for Cusack tell him not to be
afraid to come on the show Johnny's not
afraid to have anything but I think
now's the Cubs he might be he might be
keeping it a little slim no but when
they won we couldn't get him we almost
had him when they won
I'm surprised Johnny didn't come in on
that yeah he leads Cub Blue Man I the
one time I had a chance to talk to him
he's the best yes I know he wanted to
know you know it was just all inside
baseball he wanted to know the dirt he
was like what's Schilling really like
like he wanted to know that sounds that
sounds like Johnny yeah best do you hate
the Patriots fan do you hate the Eagles
the Cowboys or the Patriots more me
personally I'm not a big Patriots guy I
I'm okay with the Eagles just because
Dad was down at UPenn and some of his
greatest memories were on Franklin field
with 60,000 people cheering and so I
grew up kind of being fed some some
Eagles and the Cowboys I don't know the
Cowboys haven't been a thorn in my side
as as much as the I don't know I just
love beating the Patriots but I would
think that you wouldn't have a hatred
towards them because you beat them
I don't I mean I don't have a problem
with Tom Brady I think he's a greatest
quarterback in the history of the NFL I
wish he was I love you lie but I
wouldn't have a problem if he was on the
Giants by the way what do you do can you
be in the NFL now if you can't extend
plays with your feet or D is that the
new must I don't think you have to be
able to run as much as no I just said
yeah I can let's do listening one-on-one
I end plays I was listening John see I
think I was getting to the point I was
going to be making his Patrick mahomes
doesn't use his legs to run he keeps the
place alive Eli even Dan Marino kept
plays alive with his ability to shuffle
in the pocket Brady is able to keep it
alive by his movement in the pocket Eli
you know he doesn't have anything he
scrambled once in his life and he and he
threw the pass to David Tyree that's it
so that's the only play he ever kept
alive and it helped them win a Super
Bowl but I think you need to be able to
do that
not be able to run like candle what do
you do at the quarterback position um
well would you rather have darn 'old or
say come on Berkeley say quit Berkeley
okay
I'm believer okay
I agreed at the time that you take sake
won Berkeley because I thought the
Giants were saying Odell is back you
know we got wide receivers we've got a
good tight end we spent all this money
on defense so let's get a new I was in
that camp as well yeah new head coach
we're ready to compete for a Super Bowl
and the Giants are gonna go on a winning
streak this year where they're gonna win
five in a row later in the season would
happen against the pen what happened
against the Panthers this weekend
probably not but you're gonna have this
moment where you go where was this and
they're gonna tease you and then at the
end of the season you're gonna go man
they played pretty well at the end of
the year what do you do with Eli that's
gonna be the big question for you
john-boy what a tease the Jets coming
out that first game against Detroit that
was a tease boy but do you like moving
forward the Giants are the Jets future I
think the Giants have a lot of moving
pieces a lot of great shiny new toys yes
but if you could find a left hackle and
if you got it such sacrilege to say this
but maybe Eli is great mentoring
somebody that it's not on the squad
right now no they don't have that but
but i i'm curious what they're gonna do
with the draft but it feels like the
Giants are gonna be on the shortlist
they're a college quarterback stud that
everybody is already looking at hey
Justin Herbert of Oregon is up there
Google Giants and Justin Herbert and
you'll find a lot what there are people
salivating over that that's what section
yeah already yeah
who's the drew Locke at Missouri Locke
carrots did him but Herbert is getting a
lot of New York radio love okay Herbert
is he's the guy he died I think he's
considered the best quarterback right
now do you know now that Sunday night's
not Dan night anymore is there any you
know that great Edith Piaf song joong
Eritrea and I regret nothing
do you have any regrets about not doing
Sunday night anymore you were a fixture
you were my guy um I mean that I'm
really Jen
the complimentary legs that your great
you were great are great but rate in
that format that you were great I was
that arduous to not that decision no it
was hard on schedule harder to do the
show than to decide not to do it why was
it hard because you guys you grind so
hard here and then the weekends also
shot so that's that is the toughest part
of my week you know that hour hour and
fifteen minutes show it's you know games
are ending it like it's really your land
in planes at LAX okay right of course
but you have to make it seem like you
got everything under the throne nimble
you're so agile in that and notice that
are really hungry yes senator Hillary
you know I because I did so many live
highlights where it be like I'm I would
be watching highlights with you for the
first time seamless but I didn't want to
sign up for five more years right I
would have done two more years you guys
get to did you guys always do live or we
you guys I it seems like they go to more
locations now I'm in getting that wrong
or were you guys always in the studio
here in Manhattan we were usually in the
studio we would be the first game where
the Super Bowl defending Super Bowl
chance we'd be there on a Thursday night
we would do maybe Thanksgiving and we
would do a divisional playoff game I get
it
it just got to the point you know I went
to see my daughter in college this
weekend and and get it like I never got
to do that with my other kids so you
know I mean you miss out on a lot of
stuff as it I don't miss it though I
don't miss the if something's pretty
special between gigs I like to be daddy
the driver I like taking people to
gymnastics and the pottery and to
whatever the electives are you're not
doing at school I like driving everybody
there and I have a special needs son and
I like attending to what Max's needs are
and that's kind of the ideal isn't it
yes dad
father it's it's it's lost on people
here's something I don't know if you can
really the first thing you do when when
you when you call the agent calls and
says you know you have an offer to go to
Buenos Aires and do blah blah and I'm
like I want to go to Buenos Aires for
four months and they're like is it a
money thing I'm like no did I
Studdard I don't want to go to- Ari's
I'm really happy taking everybody to
school yeah and there's like more money
I'm like stop saying more money when
you're in your 20s though I grinded I
did about four films a year I said yeah
I just I thought once you got on the
film train if you were lucky enough to
get on the film train you should never
get off it and I didn't I don't know if
you can relate to it but whenever I win
an award and it's not very often but
when I do I I felt bad because it made
it seem like I cared more about my job
than my family yeah I get I had this
weird feeling where I'd go I want to win
but then if I win what's it's then it
feels like yeah you really dedicated
your life to your job and I was working
second shift for 15 years at Sports
Center so all my kids were born and I I
didn't see him during the week because
of the schedules you know when I get
home when they'd get up go to school so
it was crazy so I'd have these trophies
like no way around either not when
you're grinding there's no way around it
yeah you know those those Kentucky Derby
horses they wear the lines with those
blinders and when when you when you're
grinding you better have blinders on but
that's why you know these guys don't
focus on their families they focus on
this job and that's why this show is
successful and I appreciate that they
don't care about their wives and kids
they don't you see it you see in the
world
how did Oliver Stone see greatness in
what did Oliver Stone see in you he came
down I took over for John Turturro in a
play called Danny in the deep blue sea
that the guy who wrote moonstruck John
Shanley wrote and it was right over on
Bleeker at circle and John finally went
to go do desperately seeking Susan
because he was it was kind of the Wally
PIPP Lou Gehrig he just wouldn't go down
he was a beast and when he finally went
to do desperately seeking Susan I got to
take over and somebody an assistant
assistant casting person came down to
see John they saw me and so I got to go
up an audition for Oliver for the first
version of platoon which all the funding
fell out and then two years later it it
resurfaced and then he called me up and
he said McKinley do you do you want to
play one of the lead
and I was like well I was doing Hamlet
over at the public with kevin kline is
really important Hamlet and I said well
I'm over at the public doing Hamlet and
nobody in New York actor in the right
mind would have ever left that
fraternity slash sorority of being in
the Shakespeare Festival once you get in
there with Joe Papp you that was Nirvana
that was as good as it gets here and so
I said to Oliver said I gotta go ask mr.
Papp and he goes oh chill tell him it's
me and I'm like oh yeah I'm gonna say
Joe is tantamount to going in to see the
Wizard and The Wizard of Oz when you saw
mr. Papp and I'm going in and I'm like
goodnight can I go to the Phillipines
with Oliver and he's like you know an ad
was this guy had a burner all the time
when you get back and he was that was
his way of saying yes we'll we'll keep
you in because you what would have
happen if you passed on platoon I don't
know I was a working actor in New York
okay I don't know but that was different
though yeah but you can remember was a
low-budget independent it was a six
million dollar movie that certainly
wasn't gonna work out because when we
got back from the Philippines a Top Gun
was kind of the big mechanical Reagan
era or war movie and that's not what we
shot in the Philippines and then to
double down on the impossible it turns
out it was going to come out in
Christmas and nothing says Christmas
like platoon nothing I took my wife to
see the movie and she was wearing all
white we we snuck in wine and she
somebody behind her hid her seat and
spilled wine all over her so when we
came out of platoon the next next group
was coming in so they see her like oh my
god like it looked like she would she
just survived platoon and it was blood
all over her sweater and so people go
how was it and like they're looking at
her like god are they but what happened
in there and it was just wine all over
her it was the next generation of
Sensurround yeah yeah we don't want that
we don't want that your favorite line
from Point Break is you know nothing you
know less than nothing if you even knew
that you knew nothing that does
something but you don't
Paul your favorite paulie's it's got a
swear word in it why don't you astonish
me oh yeah John could maybe get away
with I don't think I could that's pretty
darn good yeah
best thing about Point Break is that
Catherine directed it so it's an
acceleration of testosterone and
adrenaline and Catherine directed it
naturally just a little more interesting
than it should have been canter Reeves
came in a couple years ago the best he
was unbelievable just he came in by
himself no PR people he was 50 at the
time you look 35 he's the best and he
just told us stories for days and I was
like I I had no idea what I was getting
with less genuinely nice it's not an act
he was really close believable
unbelievable you can see stand against
evil returns October 31st my guy can be
seen with me for voiceover I'd be more
than happy to be your voiceover guy for
standing with you Wednesdays at 10:00 on
IFC that's my guy
New York Giants apologist all-around
great guy John C McKinley and see him
and stand against evil nice Johnny thank
you we appreciate you time pleasures all
right for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]